les plaines d'Abraham ne brilleront pas
de mille feux pour le spectacle de la
Fête nationale cette année on a pris la
décision fin mai de retirer
du programme les feux d'artifice en
cette période estivale marquée par les
feux de forêt les organisateurs n'ont
voulu prendre aucun risque d'autant plus
que l'interdiction de feu à ciel ouvert
touche actuellement tous les secteurs au
nord du fleuve Saint-Laurent la dernière
chose qu'on souhaiterait c'est que les
célébrations contribuent à aggraver la
situation des feux de forêt au Québec la
ministre des Ressources naturelles
prévient que la situation demeure
critique dans la forêt québécoise en
raison des hautes températures qui sont
attendues du peu de précipitation
également qui sont annoncés au cours des
quatre prochains jours on pourrait
assister à une reprise en vigueur de
plusieurs feux ils ont ils se sont
fusionnés pour créer cette immense
brasier là dans les secteurs comme le
Bel sur kévillon la bataille contre les
flammes est encore loin d'être gagnée la
surfure veut à tout prix limiter le
nombre de nouveaux foyers d'incendie
elle invite les fêtards à la prudence
bonamalin on a toujours à peu près 5
feux de forêt qui sont causés par des
feux d'artifice qui ont c'est fait près
de la forêt ou en forêt
le commerce allumé par des amateurs qui
comportent le plus de risques si vous
avez l'intention d'en faire si c'est
permis sachez que ça peut mettre le feu
à la forêt on demande vraiment tous les
Québécois qui veulent fêter avec des
feux d'artifice ou des feux à l'ancienne
des bons feux de joie d'être extrêmement
attentif et de ne pas le faire
évidemment s'ils sont dans une zone
d'interdiction des feux présentement le
risque d'incendie est moins élevé dans
le sud de la province la septur est
évalue la situation quotidiennement elle
n'exclut pas de lever l'interdiction de
faire des feux à ciel ouvert dans
certaines régions au cours des prochains
jours ici Camille Carpentier
Radio-Canada Québec